bye
if we look now at the range of
relationships as a whole in which the
self-conscious individuality can be
observed to stand towards its outer
aspect there will be one left which has
still to be made an object for
observation
in psychology it is the external reality
of things which is supposed to have its
self-conscious counterpart and spirit
and to make spirit intelligible
in physiognomy on the other hand spirit
is supposed to be known in its own outer
aspect as in a being which is the
utterance of spirit the visible
invisible invisibility of its essence
there remains the further determination
of the aspect of reality that is that
the individuality expresses its essence
in its immediate firmly established and
purely existent actuality
this last relation is thus distinguished
from the physiognomic by the fact that
it is the speaking presence of the
individual who in expressing himself in
action
at the same time it exhibits himself as
inwardly reflecting and contemplating
himself an expression which is itself a
movement features in repose which are
themselves essentially a mediated being
in the determination yet to be
considered however the outer aspect is
lastly a wholly immobile reality which
is not in its own self a speaking sign
but separated from self-conscious
movement presents itself on its own
account and is a mere thing
hegel begins paragraph 323 by talking
about a
range of relationships as a whole a
number of as i put it here
possible relationships and what are
these relationships between
he says
in which the self-conscious
individuality can be observed to stand
towards its outer aspect so what we're
talking about
is the relationship between the
inner
of the individual something that we've
been exploring quite a lot how is that
related to the outer
as we've seen already in the previous
paragraphs there's more than one
possible
outer
so we can take you know for example my
face
my way of standing even though the
clothes that i'm wearing
uh any other sort of things like you
know what i'm showing an angry face or
happy face all those sorts of things
is
revelatory of what's going on inside and
if we're if we're doing this in terms of
lasting
dispositions we could say
we're talking about how i appear
most of the time particularly at
unguarded moments where i'm not trying
to conceal
what is within me
that's the perspective that physiognomy
is going to take and hegel is going to
contrast against it as you can see here
on the board
what he is here calling a psychological
perspective
we might think of this in terms of not
just psychology but also philosophy of
action
and ethics and moral philosophy
so what is the the contrast that he lays
out here he says
in psychology
it's the external reality of things
which is supposed to have its
self-conscious counterpart in spirit and
to make spirit intelligible so that's
that's what we're talking about here
what takes the inner which is where
spirit is and notice that he is talking
here and has been now for several
paragraphs
about spirit geist how is it expressing
itself
he says um
[Music]
you know the the
the individuality is supposed to have a
self-conscious
uh counterpart in some way to to spirit
right and so what could that possibly be
here he's talking about the outer
and the outer for the psychological way
of looking at human beings not just that
things in general but human beings
is going to have to take account of the
fact that human beings are reflexive
creatures spirit is something that is
related to itself
and can take on a variety of possible
relations to itself
so he goes on and he contrasts this with
physiognomy he says in physiognomy
on the other hand spirit is supposed to
be known in its own outer aspect right
so we're supposed to be able to know
what's going on
inside the person not just at this
moment but but throughout their life
by looking at the outer
the face
the
you know gesture all those sorts of
things
he says it's outer aspect as in a being
which is the utterance of spirit
so notice what's going on here
when we're doing physiognomy or when
we're adopting this point of view in
general
what we're after is spirit
and we're saying
spirit is expressing itself or in this
case uttering it you know the word here
for utterance is uh
which can mean language or you know an
expression or you know utterances is
just fine
so the outer is the utterance of spirit
but the outer is what we actually get to
see the outer is what we get to focus on
and by doing so we think that we have we
can then sort of read back into the
interior
and make sense out of
what what the spiritual is what the
geist diga what the mental is
what the interior is
so hegel goes on and he says
spirit is supposed to be known in its
own outer aspect the visible
invisibility of its essence
so what we've got here on this side is
an invisible essence a vason right
essence is vasen
and it can't be seen this is the
intelligible or you know i mean if we
want to adapt conscient terminology you
know the numeral as opposed to the
phenomenal right uh we don't necessarily
have to go that far but we've got an
invisible essence here
and
he says there remains the further
determination of the the aspect of the
reality that the individuality express
its essence and its immediate firmly
established and purely existing
actuality
that's not going to happen with this
that's going to happen with this
psychological perspective
instead what we get is he says the
physiognomic
winds up being just a being right so we
have invisible essence
being
read into being collapsed into something
that's external which is just a visible
being a visible zine right
vason zine
not yet actuality
not yet something that is dynamic
so let's turn now to this psychological
perspective
what can we say about that what does
hegel have to say
so again we're still dealing with the
same thing the interiority of the
individual which is supposed to be
spirit geist mind
um whatever it is that we want to read
into it this also includes sort of a
fabric of relations with with other
beings other human beings
and he goes on and he says uh reading
back a little bit
so you know in psychology it's the
external reality of things
which is supposed to have its
self-conscious counterpart in spirit
and to make spirit intelligible what
does that mean
well we look at this external reality
or external actuality
and thereby
we you know read back
just as we were with this exterior here
what is inside
but now there's a very big difference
here
there's a self-conscious
relation here
this is a as hegel pointed out earlier
this is kind of a
mute
or absurd
external uh particular right it doesn't
say anything it just it is what it is it
could be just as well be a block of wood
right you're walking around with a block
of wood for your head and it's been
carved in a certain way and there you go
right
with this what is the external reality
what is being looked at well we've
talked about this a lot
it's going to be action
and speech
so it goes on and he says
there remains the further determination
of the aspect of reality that is that
the individuality expresses its essence
in its immediate firmly established and
purely existent actuality that's that's
you know the risk here and then he says
this last relation
is distinguished from the physiognomic
why
so it's not as if we don't have you know
the individual revealing himself or
herself
in a in a way that takes on determinacy
that becomes completely actual but the
way in which it's done is no longer the
lineaments of the face
the way it's done is through action
and through speech
so he says this last relation
is the speaking presence of the
individual
who in expressing himself in action
action is expressive action is
significative action is as we've already
seen in the the previous paragraphs a
way of saying something without
necessarily using language but working
in something that's even more
at the core of actuality language is a
little bit removed from actuality
something that's at the core
because it is working with what really
is
so he goes out and he says
okay the speaking presence of the the
individual now here he says at the same
time exhibits himself as inwardly
reflecting
and contemplating himself
how
well
what is it that language affords to us
within language i can use the word as i
just did already
i
or its counterpart me or mine or any of
these other things i can say you and
mean something different from me i can
address myself in the second person oh
you greg what are you thinking right now
right i can distance myself from myself
that is something possible in language
not possible for the bones of my face
and it's something that's implicit in
action
but only truly becomes explicit for
action through the mediation of speech
right
so this is something that the
inner being
is originating it's it's it's
originating the action it's also
originating its own capacity for
reflection and contemplation
uh by taking back in
that action through what it has to say
about it or what other people have to
have to say and what it thinks about
that this is to make it uh
significative of spirits in a way very
different than the the purely
uh arbitrary external that we've been
looking at so far so he says
this is an expression which is itself a
movement features in repose which are
themselves essentially a mediated being
mediation is going on here from what is
coming out of the spiritual depth if you
like it or the interiority of the
individual um something there is being
used that's that's become actual that's
become out there in the world is
nevertheless something it can use to
mediate its own relation to itself and
to make sense of itself
so he says
in the determination yet to be
considered the outer aspect is lastly a
wholly immobile
reality which is not in its own self a
speaking sign but separated from
self-conscious movement presents itself
on its own account and is a mere thing
this is a reversion back to this
perspective of the physiognomic
the physiognomic can't offer us this
reflexivity that the psychological
perspective that focuses on action
and its meaning or significance for the
individual for other individuals who can
can witness it for the society as a
whole by the fact that it can be taken
into language turned into a universal
all that is missing here for the
perspective of physiognomy
in the first place in regard to the
relation of the inner to this its outer
it seems clear that that relation
must be grasped as a
causal connection since the relation of
one being in itself to another being in
itself
qua a necessary relation is a causal
connection
paragraph 324 is i mean almost not a
paragraph it's so short
and it's it's very straightforward
there's not that much to have to say
about it
you might wonder what the reference of
it is it's good to keep in mind
that hegel is still you know critiquing
um this this pseudoscience of of uh
physiognomy and then by implication
phrenology and other similar
pseudosciences here what he's talking
about is the way in which the inner
and the outer are related to each other
not in reality
but in the way in which that science is
depicting things so we've seen that the
outer
is treated as just a thing right it's
something that is uh
fairly static you can you can see
exactly what is going on you can start
generalizing about it notice what i
don't have on the board he uses the term
necessity here that's in part because
there really isn't any necessity
involved in physiognomy it just looks
like there's necessity this is part of
hegel's criticism the other thing is
that the inner
is thereby also being treated in in the
same way they're both being treated as
being in itself on zeke zion is and
hegel is keen to show that the relation
between the two things
the inner to the outer if we conceive of
them as both being
being in itself
must be what he's calling a causal
connection a coswell zusam and hangs you
know things that are sort of clung
together uh in a way that reflects
causality why causality because we want
to have some sort of necessity to what
we're talking about we want to be able
to say aha that guy right there is like
you know the lichtenberg example that
guy seems like a nice guy but look at
his face you can tell that he's a bad
guy he's probably going to steal from
you because he's got that kind of a cast
to his face or he's got those sort of uh
things on his head right and we're
getting towards the the bumps on the
head pretty soon but that's all that
really is going on here in this passage
hegel is setting up the pins here so he
can knock them down he's not saying that
there actually is necessity involved
he's saying that there's the appearance
of necessity and that it relies on this
notion of there being a causal
connection so now in the the paragraphs
that follow he is going to start
exploring that is there really a causal
connection or not
now for spiritual individuality to have
an effect on the body it must cause be
itself corporeal the corporeal element
however in which it acts as cause is the
organ but the organ not of action
against external reality but of the
internal action of the self-conscious
being operating outwards only against
its own body
it is not at once clear which organs
these can be if we were thinking only of
organs in general the organ for work as
such would be quite obvious similarly
the organ of sex and so on
organs of that sort however are to be
considered as instruments or parts which
spirit as one extreme possesses as a
middle term against the other extreme
which is the external object here
however is to be understood an organ in
which the self-conscious individual as
an extreme preserves
himself for himself against his own
corporeal actuality which is opposed to
him the individuality at the same time
not being turned to the outer world but
reflected in his action
and in which is an organ
which the aspect of being is not a being
for another
it is true that in the physiognomic
relation the organ is also considered as
an existence reflected into itself and
reviewing the action but this being is
an objective being and the result of the
physiognomic observation is this that
self-consciousness confronts this its
actuality as something to which it is
indifferent
this indifference vanishes in the fact
that this very reflectiveness into self
is productive of an effect thereby that
objective existence receives a necessary
relation to it but to act on that
existence the reflectedness into self
must itself have a being though not
strictly speaking an objective being and
as such an organ it must be pointed out
hegel begins paragraph 325 by saying
something that
might at first be very gratifying to
materialist reductionists that is people
who believe that everything is material
and want to account for everything else
uh whatever it is that we want to talk
about consciousness spirit
uh affections whatever else we're gonna
go on and on about they say well that it
can all be reduced
to the configurations of matter in some
way
hegel is saying here very clearly for
spiritual individuality
to have an effect on the body it must
cause
be itself corporeal now that's an
important thing
to
to point out
in order for
anything spiritual to
be more than just some kind of eerie
floaty doesn't do anything sort of idea
and that's definitely not what hegel
wants of it here
he has to have some way to engage with
the world of our bodily experience not
just our phenomenal experience
but our bodily experience where we run
into things
where we exist through our bodies
you know this is a great example of
hegel
you know he gets a bad rap as an
idealist because they think well
idealists say that there's no matter
it's all just mind or something like
that no hegel thinks that there is
matter and there is corporeality and
there is a whole world of objective
reality out there but that's not the
totality of everything and in order to
make sense of it we need something that
transcends that in some way now kant had
talked about this quite a bit
cat was wasn't the only person too i
mean you can read you know kant engaging
previous thinkers like barkley for
example who said spirit has to underlie
what we see as as matter kant reduced
things down to the opposition between
the numenol and the phenomenal and was
in certain respects unable to
really get through that impasse hegel
wants to burst through that impasse and
he's going to do it at a number of
different points
and here is in fact
one of them to you know if you want to
see it that way
so spiritual individuality
must be corporeal
in some respect
that doesn't mean that it's corporeal
through and through this isn't a
materialist reductionism right to say
that it has to be corporeal
cause
insofar as it causally interacts with
things is not to say that it is in its
essence entirely
corporeal
but it is to say that it better find
some way to connect up with this stuff
and you know it probably shouldn't be as
it was in descartes say just through the
pineal gland being manipulated uh around
sort of almost like a joystick you can
find descartes discussions of this in
his um
letters with princess elizabeth and in
his passions of the soul his last major
work
now so we've got spiritual individuality
the the interior of the person right and
hegel is now going to spell some things
out for us he's not yet going to get to
the point where he identifies the the
organ that he's got in mind that's going
to happen in just a few paragraphs
but he is interested in talking in terms
of organs
so he says
the corporeal element
in which it acts as a cause is the
organ but what organ
not the organ of action
against external reality but of the
internal action of the self-conscious
being
operating outwards only against its own
body
what organ
this is looking ahead of course
what organ do we possess
that is not so much concerned
with our interaction
with the outside world as such but
rather
guides the other parts of the body so
it's not digestion for example you must
digestions that's not about the outside
world you take things into yourself yeah
but you know you're essentially you know
digesting the world i mean flies spit up
their digestive juices then lick it all
up and so we like take things and chew
them up and put them down in our stomach
and intestines and digest them and all
that but it's really the same same
function right we're we're consuming the
world we're at least a part of the world
same thing with our hands right oh and
grabbing something definitely the
external world so he goes on and he says
it's not clear which organs these can be
what organs have the internal action of
the self-conscious being operating
outwards only against its own body what
are the ones that essentially bear on
the other organs so you said if we were
thinking only of organs in general the
organ for work as such would be quite
obvious right this
uh similarly the organ of sex uh you
know reproduction and so on
now here's the problem because organs of
that sort however are to be considered
as instruments
or parts which spirit
as one extreme possesses as a middle
term against the other extreme which is
the external object
so
these other organs that we're talking
about here
the reproductive system the
system of musculature
the digestive system um
whatever other systems we're talking
about
they perform a mediating role they are i
mean organ means tool in greek that's
the word we get you know
organ from and
you know hegel's talking about is the
middle term here so it's a a tool or a
mediation that allows us to act upon
external reality not just as a whole but
in terms of specific
parts of it i eat this food right i
chase down that mastodon and try to kill
it or maybe get killed as a result i
chip away at this this piece of rock to
make a flint spearhead
so those aren't going to work for us
where are we going to find something
that is mediating but in a different
more you might say circular or
cycloidal way so he says
here however
we're to be looking for an organ in
which the self-conscious individual
as an extreme
preserves himself for himself against
his own corporeal actuality which is
opposed to him
so
what is the middle term there it's
another organ
but the the opposition is between the
individual
the spiritual part of the individual the
interiority
and all these other bodily organs
which are an external action they're
part of the outer the the body right
what mediates within the body
between the spiritual individuality
and
the parts
or organs or functions of the body
he says the individual is at the same
time not being turned to the outer world
but reflected
in his actions now the action is
something that is out there in the
external world this is something we've
seen
it's not really action unless it goes
out there and does something
but the the external world can sometimes
be
one's own body
that's external too
i mean you can't get away from it the
way that you can
your house or the chalkboard or books
surrounding you
even your clothes right you can get away
from them if you want to you can't get
away from your own body
but it is external to you in a certain
sense
so he goes on and he says
in which
is an organ in which the aspect of being
is not a being for another it's rather
being for
self it's not just out there we have the
capacity to
have a reflexive relation with ourselves
so he says it's true that in the
physiognomic relation the organ is also
considered as an existence reflected
into itself and reviewing the action but
this being is an objective being and the
result of the physiognomic observation
is that the self-consciousness confronts
this its actuality
as something to which it is indifferent
that's a problem with physiognomy as as
a science as a discipline
we want to be able to take account of
the fact that even when we engage in
this sort of physiognomic stuff and tell
somebody hey you've got the kind of face
that makes you a thief or a poet they
actually care about it
and they they it produces something
on their own part a reorientation
towards their own body
that is something that you know i mean
we
we can see we can experience we can we
can tell happens um but you know hegel
is providing us with a sort of analysis
of that here so he goes on and he says
um this indifference the indifference of
not caring
vanishes in the fact that this very
reflectiveness into self is productive
of an effect
notice what he's saying there the mere
fact that there is this reflection going
on
already produces an effect it's not like
an effect has to be waited for it's you
know to use a phrase that had a lot of
currency back in the you know 90s and
early 2000s in continental philosophy
always already it's part of our our
constitutive way
of being
so there is some sort of
corporeality by which
we are able to you know take stock of at
least partially what's going on with the
other organs how they're expressing what
it is that that we're interested in that
we're doing that we're trying to ward
off all these different possibilities
so he goes on and he says
thereby that objective existence
receives a necessary relation but to act
on that existence the reflectedness into
self right this this organ that's that's
somehow mediating between the the
individual individuality of the body
must have a being
though not strictly speaking an
objective being and as such an organ it
must be pointed out
so there's a challenge
what organ are we talking about
what organ has this mediating and
reflexive function
that's an open question at this point
you